لقد استغرقنا شهورًا للوصول
إلى معمل موسكو السري ، حيث ساعد
هؤلاء العلماء
أنفسهم في إنشاء لقاح فيروس كورونا في روسيا ،
وقمت بتقييم
فعالية سبوتنيك
في هذا المختبر هنا ، نعم ، نعم الآن
، تم إلقاء نظرة موجزة ولكن حصرية
داخل معهد جامالايا و
فرصة لفهم
كيف تمكنت منشأة الحكومة الروسية هذه
من إنتاج ما تقول إنه
لقاح عام 19 سريًا قبل أن يكون
فريق أكبر شركات الأدوية في العالم واحدًا من المنصة
السرية حيث
يصر علماء آخرون هنا على
أنها خبراتهم بالإضافة إلى
التكنولوجيا المجربة والمختبرة
المستخدمة في  لقاحات لأمراض أخرى
أعطتهم ميزة أخرى ،
ما هو السر الذي يمتلكه الفريق ،
ولكن
ما هو السر الذي أعتقد أن
السر هو
عندما يشارك فريقك حقًا
في هذه العملية ،
وأعتقد في العديد من الأدوية أنك  لديك
مشاريع مختلفة
شاركت فيها ولكن هنا عندما
تركز على هذه
المهمة الخاصة  ar فالناس
مستعدون للبقاء هنا بين عشية وضحاها ، دعنا
نقول أن كل شخص يعمل على شيء واحد فقط
، نعم ، لا
شيء جيد ، هذا شيء جيد تمامًا ، إنه
واحد من أقدم مختبرات أبحاث اللقاحات في روسيا ،
ولكن في عجلة من أمره لإنشاء سبوتنيك ضد
نقاد يقولون إن
معهد جامالايا هذا  تخلى عن
الممارسة العلمية المعتادة بالإضافة إلى
تخطي
الاختبارات البشرية على نطاق واسع قبل الموافقة
على استخدام الجنود الروس كمتطوعين في
التجارب المبكرة
وحتى أن مدير المعهد
حقن
نفسه وموظفيه باللقاح التجريبي
الآن في مقابلة نادرة
يدافع عنها مدير طبقة جاما  أساليبه في العالم في
حالة حرب مع
covid19 أخبرني أنه يجب علينا استخدام
جميع الوسائل المتاحة للدفاع عن أنفسنا ،
لكن حقيقة أن لقاحك قد تم
تسجيله
للاستخدام قبل المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب السريرية
للأطفال
قد انتهى قبل أن نعرف ما إذا
كان آمنًا
أم  من الفعّال أنك تعلم أنه في حد ذاته
قطع الزاوية
، هل أنت مرتاح لتلك الزاوية
يجري قطع نعم ،
ربما ينبغي أن نسأل أقارب
الذين قتلوا من قبل كوفيد
إذا كانوا يفضلون منا الانتظار حتى
تنتهي المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب
أو لتطعيم أحبائهم بلقاح أظهر
نتائج مبكرة رائعة الجواب الذي يقوله
واضح
هنا  لدينا غرفتان حيث نقوم
بتنقية
البروتينات ، يمكن أن يكون على حق ، ويمكن أن يثبت اللقاح الروسي الذي
تم إنشاؤه هنا
بسرعة فائقة أنه آمن
وفعال ، ولكن إذا لم تكن السمعة
والسمعة قد تدمر ماثيو فرصة
CNN في معهد جاماليا
في موسكو